and as promised here is the man of the
hour five-time
all-pro linebacker of the seattle
seahawks who are in first place in the
nfc west heading to
western new york for a big game against
the buffalo bills in week nine
friend of the program but i don't mind
me saying so bobby wagner here on the
program how are you bobby
i'm doing good of course a friend of the
program okay good you know what i
appreciate it whenever i got time i
always gonna make you
i appreciate that bobby and i i if i'm
not are you in the weight room right now
do i hear weights clanking in the back
no we just lifted i actually i actually
woke up a little bit earlier to get a
lift hand talking so i can get on with
you
okay i appreciate that i i do appreciate
when people get a lift in before calling
into the rich eisenhower i'll be honest
with you it's it's uh
so what is a lift what is it bobby
wagner left you just fit
energy i love it what does the bobby
wagner lift look like walk me through it
what is that like
uh some some some benching some
some curls push-ups some lower body
stuff
kind of full body lift that's a good way
to start the week off
all right now let's flex here uh curls
what do we what are we curling
what's the bobby how would i i need
weights i haven't maxed out
in a really really long time you know
what that sounds like a humble break
that sounds like a humble brag coming on
the curls that's what it sounds like to
me
yeah yeah we're just gonna yeah let's
just say this is our 65
let's say that 65 uh on each side that's
uh and that's not maxing out okay
very good uh and these are the pounds
right we're not talking kilograms right
these are pounds we're talking about
nah these are pounds everything in
pounds i love it well that's what a
linebacker should be
um what are you what do you say about
this season so far
term it for me how how would you call
the seattle seahawks season to this
point bobby um
i think we you know obviously being six
and one uh we're in a good spot
i'm very excited you know kind of where
we're at just because i think
defensively we have a lot to approve and
you know for us to be six and one with
room to grow i think it's just
uh puts in us in a really really good
situation as long as we keep making
those improvements and so
um obviously offense is doing well
russell's been doing amazing dk's been
doing amazing
um tyler amazing chris carson all those
guys doing amazing
o-line with uh deep brown uh the way
they've been blocking has been great so
uh you know we're really excited about
where we're at and
how far we can grow to to be a contender
so yeah i mean it just seems if the
defense could cut down one score a game
that's uh that's being
you know put on you this might be an
unbeatable team
bobby is that the sense that uh that
yeah picking up here
yeah i definitely agree with you i feel
like uh you know defensively we've had
moments where we've played really well
we've had moments where we have not
played that well but
you know i feel like um you know last
game was a step in the right direction
and you know from this point forward
it's just about consistency and like you
said trying to clean up those yards in
the fourth quarter
so what is it like what what what is the
is the improvement i i think he just
touched on it right there it's yards in
the fourth quarter
it's it's rushing the passer being a
little bit more effective on that front
what is it bobby
yeah i think especially for last game i
think it's just being a little bit more
aggressive
i think we got a aggressive in our
calling uh in which you know
put us an aggressive mindset so you know
having
you know just being aggressive the whole
game is something i think uh
worked well for us and we just got to
continue to to protect that
and by the way uh i i did you hear you
got named defensive player of the week
just very this very morning or am i
breaking yeah nfc i just heard
just heard right on the way over here so
it's definitely a
blessing no i mean what does that mean
to you i mean you've gotten a lot of
accolades i know you're part of an all
decade team but
when when you when you get that what
does that mean for you bobby
i mean it just means that people
recognize your play
you know i think as you get older you
appreciate things like this a little bit
more because
you understand how hard it is for these
teams to come by and you have a
different appreciation for them
um as you you know get later on in your
career so
i'm definitely grateful for it i'm
grateful for my teammates
my coaches for you know making a great
game plan and
um you know it's just fun so i guess
it's bobby wagner here on the rich
island show it's kind of fitting since
we're all sitting here wondering who the
next president of the united states is
as we're having this conversation that i
now ask you about your prez
uh in jamal adams um where where where
is he
do we see him do we see him back in the
afc east i think you're visiting
he's good i think he'll he'll be back at
practice and i think uh you know he'll
get a
you know good week um in and hopefully
he's out there on sunday but you know
i'm confident with him
you know being out there at practice
there we'll see him on sunday just
knowing him again you know i'm a new
yorker and i'm a i grew up a jet fan um
so just being a fan of his and knowing
him
he seems to be a perfect fit for the
personality of your team
coaching staff etc would you agree with
that assessment
yeah definitely he came in and fit in
amazing because he loves he loves the
game he loves balls so
you know anybody who loves balls i love
it here uh because we all love ball and
coach carol shows it in his positivity
and so
you know him coming in fitting in
especially his energy you know i know
you see it on the field you know
whenever he makes a play or just his
energies
it's contagious and it's something that
you know everybody can feed off of
and so what does he bring to the back
end knowing that you're
right there in the middle that he's
behind you what does that mean
how does that work just another
playmaker another person that you have
to be accountable
accountable for you know he blesses
really really well covers really
well can can cover the tight ends cover
running backs
can make plays in the backfield but just
somebody that you have to keep your eyes
on
the whole time because if you don't he
makes plays so
you know your coach pete carroll said
locally on the radio bobby that you were
challenging your teammates to make plays
last game is that accurate
see what i'm saying he said that pete
carroll said that you were challenging
your teammates to make plays that you
were getting in people's faces a little
bit on the last game
this past week is that uh did that
happen
yeah definitely i just you know felt
like yeah you had to just
you know kind of just get in everybody's
face and just have to be a sense of
urgency sometimes
it's needed um to to kind of get us
going in the right direction
and you know understanding what's at
stake especially from defensively you
know the offense playing
as well they're playing um you know you
don't want to be
the reason why uh you know you're
potentially losing so it's just
um you know as a leader just making sure
everybody's holding themselves
accountable
as well as myself and you know putting
us in the right position to in the right
mindset to
to make those plays i mean what what is
it is it just young guys on the team or
why did you feel the need to do that
just this past week
i just think it's just from experience
you know i've had the
um i've been fortunate to be around some
amazing leaders like cam
uh sharon mike bennett cliff abreu um
and you know we've had
times like that you know and from 2012
to when they
you know either left or retired uh to
where they had to do it and so i felt
like
uh being the leader and uh being the
voice so it was my turn to
to do what they did when uh we were
young so you're the og now essentially
you've become the og
in seattle i am i i am i'm becoming the
og everybody's looking at me
i think it was funny because uh when i
was a rookie
um i told me bang when i was born
and he left because i think he was born
in like 84
and so now i find myself doing the same
thing when guys come in born in 97
and 98. yeah i mean uh that's
kind of crazy it's kind of crazy you're
you know one day you might be playing
with somebody who said yeah i was born
in 2000 i was born in 2001
you know and now you know you've got to
go line up but that's that's years down
the road but
it is amazing how you are essentially
along with russ
the bridge from one era of seahawks
football to the other
along with obviously your coach too
that's a fact
yeah definitely yeah definitely it's
interesting you know it's uh
you know you could just tell by the
music the music differences the
uh how they choose to spend their time
uh it's all funny
but uh it's been fun so keep it useful
are you turning music off
is that what you're saying are you are
you uh uh exercising your authority on
that front
no i'm not okay no i'm not that guy i'm
not that guy if
it's bad music it's bad music but i'm
not gonna you know i'll give it a chance
at first before i just turn it off okay
i understand
uh before i let you go um don't take
this the wrong way
uh but um when buddha baker was running
down the field
um you know and you saw all that
uh with dk metcalf do you do you think
you'd have been able to run him down
if you were out there with a five-yard
head start that buddha had given you do
you think you'd have been able to do it
what do you think uh i don't i don't
know i feel like i
i got buddha in a race a couple times
when we train in the off-season but
i don't know if i would have chased him
down like dk but i know when uh
you know when i i saw him get the pick i
knew dk was gonna come close i didn't i
didn't think he's gonna catch him that
quick but
uh you know i saw dk run so i knew there
was going to be a
good chance for him to chase him down
what was it like what
was that brought to the attention of the
entire team in a film room
at uh days after or day after the game
and if so what was that moment like
when you all watched it back as a team
yeah i mean
yeah when you watched it uh when you
watched it during the game you know
i think me being around for a while you
know you know how big of a play
that was because it set up you know for
us the opportunity to stop
stop them you know from scoring which i
think we did and so
you definitely have to applaud that
effort
and show that uh because that's a
example of somebody who cares and cares
a lot about the game and cares a lot
about your team so you definitely have
to celebrate that when you
see it play like that happen well we had
greg olsen on before the season
and he said that his first blush just
beginning to practice with dk metcalf
that dk had megatron type qualities like
a calvin johnson type
game you have been a world-class
defender
not on wide receivers but you have
obviously been
right there in the middle of defenses
and have seen wide receivers of note
around you where does metcalf rank to
you
uh he definitely ranks up there um i
just think his
his mentality how he approaches the game
his humbleness
um you know you have to worry about him
you know every time he's on the field
he can he can do it all he can block he
can catch uh he can chase down defenders
he's somebody that you you get up and
you watch because
you know something special is going to
happen he's just a really special player
and i don't think there's anyone like
him you the best team in the nfc you got
the best record
let's just uh give you the floor on that
before i let you go are you the best
team in the nfc
yeah you know the record says that uh we
just gotta you know keep it going you
know you've been around long enough to
know that you
can't it's hard to call it you know
right now you know there's been teams
that have started fast and didn't finish
that way so
uh we just want to be that team that
that starts fast and and finish even
better and
um i'm confident that we'll do so bobby
thanks for the call
always appreciate it uh appreciate you
getting the lift in enjoy the rest of
your uh your wednesday and we'll chat
down the road
always thank you thank you thank you i
appreciate all your help that's right
right back at you that's bobby wagner
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here